So let's talk about how to make truly scalable
pages. Now, HTML, by default, is supposed to reflow
text anyway. And text sizes are supposed to be
consistent. But the worst side effect of this viewport stuff,
by default, is that, even with nothing set, the
mobile browser is going to reflow text and render
as if the window were 980 pixels wide. And
then scale it to fit it on to the screen.
This may mean that the text looks really small on
my mobile browser by default. So, the second way to use
viewport is if your page knows how to adapt to
width. For example, if it knows how to wrap the contents
based on the screen width. You can simply the width
to device width which tells the browser, my website knows how
to adapt to your width. This is really the best approach.
To build applications that scale their own layout and make intelligent
decisions about how to do so, rather than just
trying to scale a fixed layout to fit the screen.